really why we love to do what we do is
because it's continuing dad's legacy in
an endless mission to take you're
getting married next year right at the
zoo right yes right of Australia it's a
good question maybe both maybe Robert
and a koala I was so incredibly touched
when bindi said Robert would you would
you walk me down the aisle and and yeah
I think I mean I know dad would be so
proud of you and we all will love you so
much you're achieving so much so it's
it's and Chandler who's actually here is
is such a great you know team member yes
it's exciting your daughter is getting
married but also like they're carrying
on I'm like what your husband did this
whole life that's a beautiful thing that
y'all are all like still continuing that
and changing lives exactly what he would
have wanted like how proud are you I was
very special but I do I do like the way
what how a friend of mine summed up
Chandler cuz I said to her you know
Chandler is so kind and loving and
respectful and loyal to bindi he's the
perfect guy he doesn't even drink and my
friend said to me problem a oh my gosh
you have a designated driver
[Laughter]
yes I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my YouTube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this